e
uh it's uh it's 10:02 on my uh clock so
I'm going to convene uh this hearing of
division 3 Finance um today's subject is
an informational meeting this is meaning
that uh we've asked the department to
come in and talk to us about issues uh
that are not directly related to the
budget more like programmatic issues so
today uh I'll I'll ask the committee
members to be careful to to not ask any
questions related to an answer that may
require a dollar number we're not doing
dollars today we're doing programs
growth of programs plans for programs
Effectiveness that sort of thing um
we're going to have uh commissioner
Weaver I believe start and and you may
want some people to join you what
whatever you uh
please I I always take the really big
chair I just uh yes yeah yeah I I think
they caught me on Films standing up and
yeah blame
me um be before before you get started I
I I I want to do just a little bit more
setup on this I I have appreciated uh
over the last uh four years the last two
budget Cycles um the honesty and
transparency that this committee has
received from every member of U of um
the Department of Health and Human
Service Services uh I am optimistic that
that transparency and honesty there's no
reason to doubt that that's going to
continue um the reason why some may be
concerned about it is uh I think anyone
who's reading the papers understands
this is going to be a particularly
difficult budget cycle uh we have
everyone from the governor to the Dr to
others uh letting us know that uh our
revenues are probably going to be less
optimistic than than what we might want
and uh it is our deep obligation as a
finance committee to deliver a budget
that stays within the available revenues
um it would be nice if we had uh endless
revenues and we could have uh unlimited
wants um uh and unlimited needs met but
that's not going to be this cycle so uh
so as we kick off um Commission members
of DHHS members of the committee uh I I
I can anticipate a year in which there's
going to be frustration uh during the
process and I just hope that we can
continue to main the professionalism um
W with each other uh throughout the
course of this so so thank you thank you
very much thank you representative
Edwards good morning my name is Lori
Weaver I'm the commissioner of the
department um today I have my senior
team with me here uh Nathan white CFO
and other members that you'll meet
shortly um what representative Edwards
has just references this is our attempt
um and we're grateful to have the
opportunity to have this conversation
with you to be able to tell the story of
the department without having you glaze
over and us go line by line you're going
to have that part when we get to the
budget for sure but uh really wanted to
have a chance for you to really
understand the functions of the
department um and we're going to try to
do that today this morning at a high
level and subsequent presentations we'll
do a little bit of a deeper dive so what
I was really hoping for today is to have
some time at the end that should you
have questions as we go through and you
might have a detailed question to sort
of jot that down um and at the end I'd
like to collect those um to be able to
make sure that my team is able to
respond in the subsequent presentations
and weave that uh question that you have
and to our responses um if if we have
time for that at the end we'll make time
for for that um so I believe in front of
you you have a um handout which is a
PowerPoint looks like this so this will
be sort of our uh our guide for for
today you have a couple things in front
of you I um also shared our road mapap
which I'll talk about and then there's
also this one pager which for those of
you that may not be as familiar with the
Department it lists obviously our
mission and our vision and our
responsibilities but every division um
that the department has in terms of how
it breaks down and sometimes that's a
handy reference for when you're looking
for well where does um something fall
you could put it into there um so today
how we've structured the time with you
is really I'd like to go over um some
facts and figures so a little bit of
numbers but just in terms of setting
perspective uh talking a little bit
about our road map which is really a
framework from for our priorities so
we've been working with a road map now
for a couple of years and it's a way for
us to lift up the work to be able to say
hey this is what we're charged with this
is what's we're responsible for
um and this is where uh hopefully when
you get to budget you'll be able to
crosswalk and do some um tying in with
that uh the the next couple of bullets
are really about the the Thematic focus
of when we're looking at what is the
department focused on really efficient
efficient stewardship and strong
customer service that is a theme not
only throughout our road map but through
all of our work that we do and I'll
we'll talk about that in a little bit
more um increase access to prevention
and specialized services and why is that
important especially when we're thinking
about cost right we're really talking
about keeping people in communities and
keeping them levels of care that are
appropriate to their need and and budget
uh appropriate as well um and then we
can't really talk about health and human
services without having some uh
conversation about Medicaid um so we I I
think we have a separate Medicaid 101
that director Lipman is going to provide
that will be a deeper dive but I think
for the purposes of today to sort of
give you the framework of how does
Medicaid play into all of the programs
and policy areas at the department um
and then lastly some of those questions
so if that sounds good representative I
okay so a little bit on the facts and
figures I'm sorry I'm just a little slow
I I had meant initially to point out
that uh representative tersi had let us
know she's going to be about 15 minutes
late so she's on her way and I don't
know where representative norvanco is
but uh he may come in I've got a request
from representative Daniels to allow him
to leave at 11:15 I think he want to
leave at around a little bit before 11
so so we'll TR try to keep moving yep
thank you I believe we'll get there um
this is sort of a highlevel uh view
really you know our vision for the
Department is really about our citizens
in the state having Optimal Health that
that is our goal and the department
plays a big role in that um we have
three primary responsib posibilities if
you think about well what does the
department do it's so large you can
chunk it out into protection and
prevention Client Service delivery and
Regulatory oversight so as I've
mentioned we have um we have eight
divisions six of those are direct policy
or programmatic related divisions as
they're listed there and then we have
two which the division for finance which
Nathan our CFO overseas and then our
quality improvement and integrity um
unit uh division as well so that's the
bulk of of our organization when you
look at some numbers um yes for this
fiscal year we have a $3.6 billion
budget obviously that's not all General
funds um we have a lot of federal and
other Revenue sources so that's a lot of
money and we're about
53% of the in total uh state budget for
General
funds in our staff represent when you
think about all of the state positions I
think there's last I knew there was
around 12,000 we're about about a fourth
of all state positions but yet when you
look at our budget our Personnel costs
are really less than 11% of our whole
budget so I just wanted to point that
out that oftentimes when we think about
reductions and budgets the first place
we go to personnel and for sure and
that's something we do every single year
whether it's a reduction year or not um
obviously mindful of that this year
there's just recently a hiring freeze um
which obviously is going to impact um
our ability um to hire um but that 11%
isn't uh necessarily where the money is
at for a big chunk of reduction there's
some for
sure and then sure I I for the folks who
are new to this this $3.6 billion budget
as I understand it is federal state and
and other sources of which um uh the
general funds is is about 1 Point 217
billion so so about a third of the total
budget I understand is General funds I
will say in my my commissioner rough
estimates yes but Nathan will give you
the exact yes that's roughly correct all
right thank thank you I just wanted
people following to see what the numbers
are uh you're you're
over all right welcome I'm glad you're
safe you continue so and just uh
continuing a little bit on the next page
for Staffing um this is how our position
counts break out um so I just want to
point out that with the exception of any
required legislation the department did
not make any new position requests so we
go through uh Every Spring being
prepared for that we made none except
for what was legislatively required of
us uh 50% of what you're looking at here
50% of our Workforce roughly is what we
call Direct Care so client facing or
client serving that's why you'll see
larger numbers in DCF or in economic
stability or at New Hampshire hospital
um and then obviously you know you have
Medicaid to to your point we have a lot
of money in our Medicaid service we have
about a team of 33 in the Medicaid space
um as opposed to some of the other areas
so we have a legislative cap of cannot
go over
3,000 um approximately we're about 11
shive being at 28 00 filled as of today
um I do expect that to change with the
hiring freeze and attrition will happen
we do have some car outs for direct care
but attrition is constant so I do expect
that number to change um in the last two
years we've reduced our vacancy rate
quite significantly from 22% to 14% so
there was a lot of effort that went into
that and then trying to retain those
staff and keep those staff again a
hiring freeze I expect to see that
number start to move again
um and and ultimately it matters because
that's going to really dictate if I
don't have Workforce there's some things
I can do and some things I can't
do um the next slide is really on our
budget complexity and I'm going to let
nethan um explain this one but in terms
of a little bit about what
representative Edwards was saying
earlier our budget is not uh just one
for uh funding source however there's
lots of other requirements and some
complexity to how it all works
great good morning members of the
committee Nathan white Chief Financial
Officer uh good to see some returning
members I look forward to working with
new members that I haven't yet had an
acquaintance with this slide in front of
you I know we're not going to be talking
too much about budget but I don't
necessarily think you can talk about the
programs of course unbiased without
talking about the budget and in front of
you this slide it it it presents some of
the dynamic nature of hhs's budget and
one of the reasons that some people some
S have a challenge understanding why is
HH budget so complex and and the saying
that I always like to say is it's
complex but it's all explainable and so
if you look at the first Circle there
that is the budget and so we prepare our
budget the agency budget in August we
make certain assumptions we assume we're
going to have X amount of vacancies we
assume that we're going to have um X
percentage of clients for this
particular service we we assume these
expenditures are going to be X based on
a certain
population and then and then we have the
actual so once the budget is passed then
we actually then we move into the actual
and then we see what really happens and
you you have to remember we prepare our
budget our agency budget 10 months be
before the budget actually goes into
effect so because our budget again it's
only it's a little over a tenth
Personnel most of our budget a lot of
our budget is in Medicaid it's in Direct
Services provided to to Citizens there's
contracts and we don't necessarily know
what that spending is going to look like
because that spending is going to be
responsive to the needs of the
population of the citizens of the state
and then there's a there's a third
component in you'll see that that bubble
on the right cost allocation and so HHS
we use a cost allocation system um we
have a it's called a pay cap a public
assistance cost allocation plan it's a
several hundred page document I don't
recommend reading it but what that does
is it basically lays out the framework
in which we're able to leverage federal
funds and we assign those federal funds
towards certain efforts so for example
some of our employees may be paid with a
couple of different funding sources it
might be tan if dollars it might be
44e and they do random time studies
during the month and random moment
studies and some other methodologies and
then we assign okay you worked on title
4E projects a certain amount that means
you get to earn more 4E and then and we
go through a regular process um and we
have a team that does this to make sure
that we can leverage those federal funds
and so it's it's these three components
that kind of feed into um the HHS budget
and then on top of that like when you're
thinking about sort of the middle here
there's other complexities on top there
where you have maintenance of effort
requirements so one of the um one of the
topics that we discussed uh
representative or chairman Edwards last
time a lot was TANF so we have to spend
30 $4 million of General funds in order
to get or excuse me 32.4 in order to get
$38 million of federal funds each year
and if we don't spend x amount of
General funds then the subsequent year
we have an equal penalty and then we
have a reduction and so sometimes when
you're looking at positions you go to
abolish this position well yes but that
may impact our ability to spend towards
that tanif Moe and and I just kind of
want to recognize those complexities
before we start getting into um into
some more of the details so that when we
say oh well what does that contract do
that contract does this but you have to
remember that also helps us meet our our
Medicaid requirements and and things of
that nature so um I'll kind of pause
there and hand it back over can I ask
you a question then yes so uh so that
suggests that uh historically then that
you've done an accounting to show how we
accum ulated our our tan contribution
and that and that uh that that would
give us some sense of how Divergent
those sources of of uh contributions are
could you is there something simple
enough is this like five pages of
spreadsheet or is it a 100 or what what
what what what what would we be looking
at if you were to share with us
historically looking tanif uh
contributions um we would probably want
to simplify what we have internally but
I could take it back to the team and we
could see what we could put together to
kind of demonstrate because that match
is going to be met by many different
positions in many different areas and
contracts and other factors but I don't
want to get too far into the weeds today
no I I don't want to either I'm just
asking if if you could provide it in a
way in which we could get a sense of how
complex it is that you just described us
because I agree with you that it's an
important factor for us to understand
how embedded and intertwined these
contributions can be we can do that for
you absolutely thank you and so before
we leave that I just in terms of
positions one thing that we worked out
last bium uh budget wise is in terms of
uh with positions letting the department
being able to hit a Target rather than
going through and this position and that
position knowing the complexity of what
is behind each position for funding
mechanism Okay so moving to uh the next
slide so the road map so you have I I
shared with each of you a hefty uh
document it's also available on our
website I printed out the color copy
only special people get the color copy
um being mindful of resources um our
road map is really our framework right
so this is the Department's priorities
and what I'd like to be able to do today
as I walk through high level for you is
also weave in some of those themes that
I was talking about earlier of what
we're focusing on here um our road map
app was just for brief history uh short
mid long-term goals developed internally
and with stakeholders so we didn't do it
in the vacuum we went and got feedback
on it our staff at all levels have
participated in working with uh the team
to lift this up so that there's
ownership um and that people understand
the work so it's not creating new work
it's a frame of same work of the work
and it's a way for us to be able to say
when people say what are your priorities
Department we're able to sh to point
them to this document so it breaks down
into about three the three different
bubbles that you have in there I call it
the three C's culture community and
customer service so if we look at uh the
I'll start with the the um the bubble
the purple bubble promote thriving
communities really this is where a lot
of our policy work is this is about uh
Client Services the right service at the
right time for the right
individual when we think about what is
uh some of the themes that we're looking
at is really access to specialized
services so we have a lot of our
different programs in here that you're
going to hear about um but we have a
high focus on making sure that there is
access for people to receive those
services that they needed um the bullets
on beneath it I should put my glasses on
um there these are the uh main uh
initiatives under there I'm not going to
go through all of them as you're going
to hear about them I just want to
highlight a couple for you um so you
some of you may have heard about Mission
zero that is one of our uh initiatives
and priorities about ending emergenc
Department boarding so we've had a
concerted effort over two years with our
partners internal and external to be
able to bring the number down of folks
sitting in EDS So when you say what is
your priority priority is to make sure
right service right person at the right
time right that people don't have to go
to the highest level of care um if
they're experiencing a mental health
event there may be lower levels of care
um so that is something that we've had a
focus on um as well as quite a lot of
success on U moving down sort of in the
middle of it is improve access to a
broad range of communitybased and
residential Behavioral Health Services
so that's not only for CH children in
our system but that's also for our
adults as well and so you think about
inhome care services uh not for some of
our seniors and older adults um but also
for kids not every kid needs to be in a
residential placement what are what is
the Continuum spectrum of services that
they can be receiving to keep them out
of res care so that is a priority for
the Department is to reduce Reliance on
institutional care and to be able to
increase community- based care so you'll
hear that theme throughout um and that
ties in a little bit with our system of
care for healthy aging which you'll hear
more about as well but there's been a
lot of progress um on that front as well
so we have two systems of care we have
one for children and we have one for
adults um pretty much with primary focus
of trying to keep folks in their
communities while receiving services so
that's the bulk of our work uh the the
customer service side of it that bubble
on the bottom there in the middle um
that falls into our theme of uh
efficient effective use of our resources
right are we are we being efficient and
mindful of what we have how we're
spending it and and how it's being
utilized and also strong customer
service so I'll just highlight a couple
for you here in terms of the Contracting
experience when you think about the the
dollar amounts that we have invested in
our contracts a lot of that money is
given to our providers in state to
provide these Services right so whether
they're Community Based whether they're
or more
intensive okay I was gonna say it's not
okay why talk about sweating
huh not in California okay
um I got to recollect my thoughts there
uh so so my point being is uh for
contractor Services a couple of points
here so if we have we are responsible to
make sure that we get people served and
we draw down this money and we have all
this money and now we've got to procure
it we've got to get it out into Services
which means we've got to work with our
partner providers in the community so a
couple of things here from the external
side for the last two years I've focused
with our Center for nonprofits
organization to work with all of our
providers to say how can we do this
better so we isn't just the department
it's obviously the state if you know
anyone if you have a colleague anyone
that says hey when to do a contract for
the state they're a great vendor but
sometimes it's really hard with a lot of
bureaucratic processes and paperwork so
we're trying to make that easier at the
department level and beyond that because
we need our provider Partners they carry
out this work it's not the department
staff that do it so there's that
external side to make sure that we get
good provider Partners the internal side
is our are making sure that we asked and
contracted for the right things right
what are we investing in what is the
outcome what are the deliverables and
are we getting it so there's a couple of
pieces there there's good contract
management writing there's good
negotiations with vendors Partners but
there's also
measuring uh the outcomes as we go along
so good active contract management so we
as a department are responsible if we're
going to take this money and put it out
there we need to all along the way make
sure that it's hitting the mark and if
it's not to be able to course correct so
that we don't get at the end of a 2-year
contract and say well yeah that didn't
work and then we have all that money
that didn't get us to where we where we
needed to go so that has been a big
focus of our road map and that efficient
stewardship of our resources that's a
big big big piece of it um another piece
of it is our data driven practices so
really trying to um increase our use of
data and dashboards to with all of our
services so that we can look at what is
the data telling us for where we need to
drive for that service not where we've
driven for 30 years or where we think we
need to go but where the data tells us
to go so um that's helping with future
planning and it's also happening
happening helps with current management
as well so and there's a lot more pieces
in customer service I just wanted to
pull up and highlight um some of those
for you here and we're going to talk a
little bit about more about some of
these in the next
slide and the last bubble but probably
for me one of the most important bubble
is my Workforce uh if I don't invest in
people and culture I'm not going to able
to do anything else in the other bubbles
so I need to have a Workforce that's
competent uh that is satisfied with they
do um and consistent right so that has
been our focus when we're looking at you
know when I don't have enough staff this
is where we see all of these things
start to fall short so I have to have
enough staff to be able to maintain the
minimum of what we're doing and just in
terms of Staffing just as a quick aside
we we have looked at over the last
couple of years other states of a
similar size and demographic population
even with a Medicaid population served
and so we know that we're not
overstaffed and we know that we're not
woefully understaff notice I say
woefully right uh we're sort of right in
the middle all right so we we have we we
can we're making it work with what we
have but we I don't want to be woefully
underst staffed I guess is is some of
the the ask there so just keeping that
in mind that we're not overstaffed at
this point we're able to carry out our
mission so so you're going to hear about
uh our road map uh repeatedly throughout
budget sessions because it's what our
staff know as our priorities it's what
our stakeholders know as our priorities
and it's what I want you as our division
three budget committee to know as our
priorities going
through uh you um I I don't know if uh
this has been done I I'm not asking for
new work but if it's been done I'd like
to see it at some point is um I I love
the road map I've complimented you every
time I've seen the road map this is
really excellent strategic work thank
you for that um what what would be
helpful as we go through this is uh the
the budget as it presents in hb1 is a
very kind of you know linear uh
spreadsheet and uh what would be useful
I think as another way to look at this
is if almost if there was a a pivot so
that we could see these line items of
the Strategic plan and have some sense
what each of these bullets are are going
to uh consume in terms of resources uh
financial and Personnel so so this this
is the way I I I I think you view your
department and leading your department
it would be nice if we could see how the
resources then kind of pivot up
underneath it and support the Strategic
plan I I I think Miss Tellus is
scheduled to come in and and tell us
about your road map and the performance
metrics that you've established for
these things at least that's what I
think she's going to do if if it happens
that we she could maybe oh no it's still
too early to talk numbers um but
eventually it would be cool if we could
get numbers associated with the
Strategic plan is it is that hard to do
do so we're anticipating following a
similar presentation style to what we
did in the in the prior banum where what
we did is we tried to line up all of the
accounts and the bureaus and we tried to
tie those into a narrative around the
program so I think what we can do is as
we go through that is we can highlight
key elements but part of the road map
too is prioritizing certain things so
there's certain staff that exist today
they existed before the roadmap started
that are now prioritizing the road map
initiatives maybe over some of the work
that they may have done other otherwise
or other initiatives so but what we can
try to do is just highlight that maybe
we can use a little identification
system a little asteris or something
along those lines to try to get out what
your what you're identifying chairman
Edwards so I this this kind of question
came up in a previous presentation on
Mission zero and Mission zero is this
very comprehensive program that brings
all the these components together for
success and it's beautiful the way
that's working uh I think I think I
asked at that time if there was a way
for us to do a cost estimate of what
mission zero was costing us from an
execution perspective and that sounded
like a very tough question
um well I I think we could speak to the
direct cost that the department had with
its relation missions ER but when you
think about if you're going to quantify
all the time of all the external
stakeholders and count that as a cost as
well that might bring a level of
complexity to
it I think so we can quantify some of
the costs for that internally for the
Department like we stood up positions
for one of the initiatives um that we
didn't have before to to be able to do
that work all right thank
you right so at this point I'd like to
um go to the next Slide the clerk has a
question do you have a question chairman
may have you may I ask a question I have
a quick question
uh and looking uh under the mission zero
again a quick comment I'm uh
representative Rich nenco from chesher
District
9 uh and the question is under the
bullet that says reduce the health
impacts from environmental threats what
a summary of what's included under
environmental threats sure we're going
to go through all of those uh detailed
questions at subsequent presentations so
we will make sure to write that down
thank you for the question thank you um
so the uh next slide of efficient
stewardship of resources and strong
customer service that theme that sort of
laying out I'm going to ask Dave weers
to come up and join Nathan here to walk
you through um some of these systems
here although we could sit together we
good morning my name is David weeders
I'm the Chief Operating Officer for the
for DHHS thank you for having me here um
chairman Mr chair and the members of the
committee
so taking off of what um commissioner
Weaver just indicated in order to
achieve a lot of these um road map items
as well as providing good customer
service we really need to have a way in
which to be efficient with that so it is
always historically been the the promise
of automation the promise of efficiency
the promise of making it easier or
faster to do things our goal is to try
to do that in concert with the services
that we're doing and so the information
systems that we have here is really that
one of the things I've learned over the
last six years of work working and
living in New Hampshire is making sure
that we address everything from a
privacy first perspective and then
security and then making making sure at
the same time how do we efficiently meet
the expectations of our constituency
meet the expectations of our legislature
meet the expectations of our governor's
office and really meet the expectations
of our commissioner as well to achieve
those goals of customer service so we
currently support a little over 130
applications in the department across
all of the different programs and in the
area we partner with Department of
Information Technology to be able to
support those as well as several
contracts um that we work with the
contracts division to
do amongst those 130 applications we
have really eight key platforms and the
reason why I call them key platforms is
they're really key enablers for us to
automate and actually reduce duplicative
effort and provide efficiencies where
where possible so we're not building
multiple different systems to do very
similar components so about 6 years ago
actually said our applications were
closer to 200 applications that we
supported so we've actually reduced our
application over the last six years
those platforms include and you'll hear
in my presentation tomorrow some more
details about these but those those
application platforms are the Medicaid
enterprise system which is really made
up of 14 different um systems in itself
that are achieving different components
of Medicaid uh Solutions then we also
have the Enterprise business
intelligence system that we will call
ebi you'll so I'm going to try to always
Define any acronym that I use um I I
definitely as an IT person have that
challenge and so anytime you have a
question feel free to say what is that
NH here so then the next one NH Care
Connections or New Hampshire Care
Connections is our system that really
focuses on improving our coordination of
care but also really focusing on
emission distri transfer shared care
insights and Clos Loop referral so
you'll hear a lot about that You'
probably heard a lot about it over the
years I know a number of you have been
in rooms with me talking about Clos Loop
referral but it is much more than just
Clos Loop referral so you'll hear more
about that as
well and then we have Granite families
or Bridges so we have a current um
comprehensive child welfare information
system which we call Bridges it's a 20
plus year old system that we've been
migrating to to what's called Granite
families through funding with
Administration for children um
children's and families um support and
and then we also have new heights which
you'll hear me say New Heights a lot but
they'll also be inclusive of New
Hampshire easy so new heights is our
integrated eligibility and enrollment
system but it's become so much more in
the last couple years where it also
supports developmental disabilities so
instead of implementing a whole new
system um based off of doing rfis and
work with different contracted vendors
we identified a way in which to expand
upon the new heights platform to achieve
that goal with a with a reduction in
cost overall cost and then we have
options which is for our aging and adult
population um we're still using that
system it is a um doit supported
application that we're looking to
replace over the over time and you'll
hear more about that and then the last
two are Avatar which is an electronic
health records or electronic medical
record system that we use currently at
New Hampshire
hospital and then Salesforce and
Salesforce as a platform has enabled us
to implement dozens of solutions um
within our department in a much quicker
fashion than in the past um where we
would have to go out to RFP Implement a
a silo based solution and then take it
Forward um for maintenance and
operations with the Salesforce platform
we able to in some cases deliver
Solutions in 3 days during covid we
actually implemented Granite trace for
case investigation and patient
monitoring for covid in three days over
a weekend to ensure that we could
collect that and other systems like our
like child care licensing and registry
solution for child care and how start
development as we go through this and
streamline these Solutions you'll hear
more about when I'm what sort of what
you were asking representative Edwards
where we how do we tie it to our road
mapap so the tomorrow's slide will go
into more detail as to what are the
Technologies behind some of these road
map initiatives and how what are the
where the human resources taking how is
the architecture supporting it and how
are we moving it and I can I'm probably
going to not go into the details of the
architecture but I certainly will
address the different um technologies
that are supporting these road map
components and then going into that
second column portfolio management is a
key component of how organizations
really manage their initiatives how they
manage the prioritization of their work
and how they manage the overall health
over the past several years we've been
standing up the Enterprise portfolio
management solution and our goal is to
leverage pinok which is project
management book of knowledge it's a
standard best practice in the United
States and agile project management
methodologies to really adopt some of
those risk risk management issue
management scheduling resourcing and
then overall health of a project we've
been using that to manage an average of
200 projects annually and we've really
been aggressive at using it for our road
map initiatives to ensure that we can
see that it's staying on track and how
we're moving it
forward I'm going to I'm not going to go
through every bullet here but we have
invested in a lot of training to ensure
people have the resources that they need
to be able able to adopt these
methodologies and then using our
oversight and Leadership we've been able
to coach and move a lot of projects
forward faster using these Technologies
and I'll hand it over to Nathan to go
through our Contracting great thank you
Dave uh at the Department of Health and
Human Services we have a centralized
contracts unit and our Bureau and what
that team does is they prepare all of
the solicitations so all the rfps and
the rfas and the rfbs and they also
handle all the contract amendments and
Grant agreements and our lease
agreements and our regular contracts and
a whole Sue of Other M Moes
intergovernmental
organization um agreements as well and
part of the reason that we've
centralized that function uh going back
to the commissioner's point is to ensure
that the contracts are developed in a
solid way and have meaningful
performance measures have enforceable
provisions and ensure that we're getting
the things that we want and there's um
there's standard templates and
procedures and members that are trained
on this regularly and they work with um
the program areas and Leadership across
the department and they they put through
a tremendous amount of volume and I
think it's important for this Committee
just to remember that every contract
over $10,000 has to go through the
executive counsel process and any if you
change one word in any contract that's
been approved by the executive Council
that Amendment needs to go go back
through the executive Council so this
team moves 7 800 and some years even
more than that amendments and contracts
through that process and they've
implemented a lean Six Sigma uh demic
culture and I think that's really
important because basically what that
means is they're constantly measuring
what they're doing they're rethinking
what they're doing and they're striving
to do that faster and more efficient and
it also what's really important if um if
you've uh been involved in lean Six
Sigma the the voice of the customer is a
very important component here and we've
developed this system both for internal
customers but Al also the provider
community and those individuals in the
community that are responding and that
system's been intentionally built up
that way over a period of years to
address deficiencies that leadership had
identified six seven eight years ago and
we've made some really good strides now
they also conduct risk assessments so
anytime we're giving out money to a
provider um we conduct a risk assessment
we look at the the operational risks and
we also look at the financial risks and
that's really important because we then
set the contract up based on the risks
that we've identified and the level of
oversight and monitoring and I'm going
to kind of switch the budget for just a
sec but when you look at our budget
lines we do have hundreds of millions of
dollars in our contracts lines and
that's why it's so important to make
sure that when you're developing that
contract you get it right you make sure
it's enforcable but and now I'm going to
switch to Quality and
performance but it's also important that
you include meaningful performance
measures and so Meredith too will be
here tomorrow and she'll be talking
about some of what her team does and her
team is now working with different
program areas to try to incorporate
those Provisions that will make those
contracts have better outcomes and give
us the ability to measure what are the
outputs what are the outcomes is that
really worth it you know that that's
what we want to try to make sure that
can do uh she's also going to be talking
about um we do audit our providers on a
regular basis um when we identify risk
there's certain requirements to make
sure that those dollars are spent
accordingly um we we also actively look
at um the financial Integrity of some
some of our smaller providers or some of
our high-risk providers we look at their
financials on a monthly basis to make
sure that there's no solvency issues and
if we start to see Trends um we do
intervene at time and have a
conversation to get a better
understanding because as the
commissioner was indicating we do rely
on our providers through our contracted
or through our contracts or our grants
to deliver key critical services and so
you know we're we're both we're we're
we're Partners but we're also ensuring
that the dollars are being used
effectively um and in responsible ways
so um Meritus team also has a fraud
waste and and uh abuse team that
regularly looks at into um suspicions of
fraud and she's going to go into a
little bit more of that tomorrow but I
just kind of want to provide sort of a
high broad overview of all the different
activities that um that that the
department does relative to ensuring
funds are uh are managed appropriately
so and with that we can move May oh yes
um okay
I I have known that you've been
improving the contract management since
your arrival and it continues to sound
like you're reaching a higher level of
professionalism the one one thing that
uh has caught my ear this time around
and the commissioner mentioned it and is
I'd like to maybe when you come back to
talk about contracts more
deeply I'm I'm interested in the the way
in which you're interfacing with the
public because it sounded like you're
you've made a point of making our
contract availability more known and
easier to access so that we can increase
bids and interest in public
participation uh that that that's kind
of new to me that that's an area that
you've worked on and if if I've heard
you right I'd like to just know more
about it but but not today absolutely
we've provided a presentation um to
another committee and and we can uh
refurbish that and bring that back so we
can give you that information absolutely
all right thank
you and with that I'm going to hand it
Commissioners thank you so much my name
is Patricia Tilly I'm an associate
commissioner here at the department and
I'm Chris santanello I am also an
associate commissioner this feels like
oversight it does it does indeed um I'm
going to start a little at start first
and then I'm going to hand it over to
Chris we're going to work
synergistically together before I get
started though because we all felt the
rocking and roll in a few minutes I'll
just give you an update it was a 4.1
earthquake in Portsmith there are no
Health needs in the towns or hospitals
in the region so there you go that's
what we're doing in the back while we're
while you all are presenting we're
making sure that everything's safe and
sound um for um right now the other
piece that I'll start and answer before
I get into the slide a little bit was
the question earlier around
environmental threats I can tell you
that we'll talk a little bit more you'll
hear more about that probably when
public health comes and does their um
description of their budget but I to
answer your quick question what we're
very much focusing on is pasas we are
focusing on lead lead both in homes lead
in water um we're focusing on food
safety and contaminants in foods and
supporting our health officers in our
towns so that you'll hear more about
that when when public health comes and
presents later on so let me jump in
right now for right now um we're going
to focus on Thursday Chris and I around
the specialized services and the
population Health work that we do within
the department um and we're going to
dive in we're going to talk a little bit
about youth we're going to talk about
older adults we're going to talk about
the specialized services that they need
at a high level we're going to focusing
on focus on the ways that we streamline
Services as a single agency the
department creates a more integrated and
coordinated system hopefully making it
easier for families and individuals to
get the care that they need and the
services um in a coordinated fashion and
sometimes in one place we believe that
this reduces confusion and um the helps
us prevent the need to multip to
navigate multiple
bureaucracies um we think that together
we are working on efficiency in our
resource allocation by having all of
these programs under one Ruth you again
as a small state we pride ourself on
efficiency as we've heard over and over
and in this budget season especially and
by combining Services Under One Roof um
it's maximized available funding
Staffing and infrastructure and this
includes some of the things that I know
that um representative Edwards is
interested in around evaluation and
monitoring those many contracts that um
Nathan was just describing we're also
going to talk a little bit about our
data sharing with all the service these
Services under one agency there's better
potential for appropriate data sharing
we have lots of conversations about
security and privacy in many of our
efforts but by having someone like Dave
weeders in Charge who has an eye on all
of those systems we're able to more
efficiently share information and to
improve the services that we have and
that that really leads to a more
holistic approach to Service delivery um
many of the individuals and families who
use um require services in one part of
the department also require services in
another department part of the
department and that's why working
together we are focusing on how to make
sure we streamline that along the way so
that we get to improved
coordination our road map in particular
as the commissioner noted focuses on um
Mission zero um we're going to dive into
that a little bit more on Thursday the
spoiler is we did have gotten to zero in
the mission zero it's hard to sustain
that and that's why you're going to hear
about the multiple funding streams to
your question earlier representative you
know the reason it's hard for us to give
you a single answer is because it the
foundation is so complex we use Medicaid
we use individual grants we use General
funds and they're from all different
parts all coming together to be able to
lift up this initiative so that we can
reduce the burden of emergency
department boarding for people who are
experiencing acute mental health needs
we all know that's not that is not what
we want and we can you we have used
Mission zero to focus energy to use
every lever we have to lift that up to
make change we're going to focus um as
the commissioner also noted on the
system of care coordinated systems for
children and Behavioral Health there is
not one of us who hasn't experienced in
our own families or our friends and
neighbors the impact of the Mental
Health crisis among children in the
state and so we are looking to better
coordinate that care and make for both
the population of kids that we are in
charge of that we have care and control
of through dcyf as well as for your
neighbors and for your constituents and
through that we're really looking at
aligning or embedding prevention
everywhere centralizing a place to call
for help scaling helpful Services
strengthening supports to stay home and
out of those institutions where possible
and coordinating expert care when we
need it so um you one a few of the other
things we'll poke at on Thursday is
really uh focusing on dcyf a little bit
you know that's in plays hand inand with
our system of of care of Behavioral
Health but there are also some
particular issues that I know may be
interested of this committee around the
senu Youth Services Center and that
transition to a new facility so we'll
dig into that a little bit so I'm going
to hand it over to Chris and let you
take it from there right thank you could
you just give me just one moment I out
of respect for the commissioner's time I
I think you're getting ready to to leave
do you have any final words or thoughts
you okay all right sorry for the
interruption no no no problem um I think
also what we want to cover on Thursday
is the system of care for healthy aging
and how as an aging State we are working
collaboratively with our partners with
the state Commission on Aging to
increase our ability to provide Home and
communitybased Services um in um instead
of institutional care um we're going to
talk about that we're also going to talk
a little bit about the preventative
programs that we have under older
Americans act which actually help
provide supports to older adults before
they need um more more significant level
of care before they have Medicaid so
something like Meals on Wheels is a
really important program because for
many people who access it that's the
only contact they have with somebody so
it provides a lot more um than nutrition
um we're going to also talk a little bit
about how we're working together um like
I said with the state committee on Aging
um with some of that work and also Adult
Protective Services that is required
under state law but what is the
interface for how we support um
vulnerable adults as well as our aging
and disability Resource Centers how
they're um critical as part of the
system of care to help increase access
the right service at the right time at
the right place we'll also spend um a
significant amount of time on our
developmental Services System um and and
how we're strengthening that um and
building rate work to help us have
predictable um
standardized approach to um services
using an assessment based approach that
will help us over time um to really have
but better um budget predictability so I
think that's it in the interest of time
um I will have an Step Up um may I say
something about public health sure um I
one of the things I've been thinking
about as we're grappling with the
challenge of the of the coming budget
cycle is that we we just went through an
enormous change in our Public Health
expectations because of covid and so so
I'm I'm just wondering at a very simple
sophomoric level as I go into this what
if we were to take as a baseline
2019 and looked at the programs that you
want in
2025 is being additive to that so that
we can understand which ones are driven
by the crisis and which ones are just
driven by greater public health
awareness and and we don't have to do
that today but I just wanted to share
with you sort of my simple sophomoric
view of how to think about your Public
Health Mission thank you and and the
only respon I think that's great we can
talk about that further in the public
health um discuss of the budget the
thing I would leave you with is that the
greatest um there were not many gifts of
the pandemic but one of the small gifts
was the ability to modernize our data
systems and so I don't think of that as
additive I think that that it was an
opportunity to use an influx of federal
funds to get our our Data Systems to the
be it's so cter intuitive I I just want
to um I didn't realize that Croc was
wrong so it's actually 10:55 so I I do
have to run across the street but um I
wanted to um Ann's going to come up and
and work the next slide but I just
wanted to say thank you for the
opportunity um and I'm going to pray
that it's not a bad Omen that there was
an earthquake in the middle of my
resentation and my chair was shaking so
um but Ann you want to come come up and
so I think after Ann's piece on the
Medicaid if we could just get for from
you your thoughts in terms of things
that are uh questions you may have had
that you want to make sure that we
address um in subsequent presentations
you good
morning um my name is an Landry I'm one
of our associate Commissioners and I'm
here with of Jonathan Balor to work as
the chief medical officer and while you
may be surprised that well at least I'm
here on behalf of Medicaid because
you're used to director lipin I'm just
going to give you a brief overview of
our Medicaid Program and and walk you
through some of the um Concepts and and
intricacies of the program that Henry
will will walk us through on Monday or
next Monday
so um here our slide really depicts um
how Medicaid funding intersects with all
of the different programs um that we
execute in the Pro in the department and
Beyond but really as you know Medicaid
is the insurer for our most vul vble
residents and citizens um in the state
and those with the most complex needs is
really is that Lifeline for those
individuals who cannot um Access
healthcare anywhere else um so clearly a
critical program it really covers
specific populations it's it's not just
anyone who can get Medicaid obviously
it's individuals with low incomes
whether that's pregnant women children
families and a certain um group of
adults it's individ idual with
disabilities and then elderly
individuals um and as we know Medicaid
the Medicaid Program really has two um
two different components it's it's the
required Federal components of Medicaid
whether that's impatient and outpatient
hospitalization for example and then the
New Hampshire approved optional benefits
which as you know the most recent is
really um Dental um Dental benefit so
there's a wide range of of required and
then optional benefits that Henry will
walk us
through we also know that and um that we
deliver these Services through a couple
of different mechanisms there State
there state plan amendments that some of
our services are covered through and
then Federal W federally approved
waivers which for example our Managed
Care organizations our our Managed Care
Program is covered through a waiver so
again um on a week from say Henry will
really walk you through how what are the
differ between services covered by state
plan Amendment what are services covered
under waivers what are the differences
where is our overlap where do we um
leverage those different mechanisms to
best serve the residents of New
Hampshire and how do we hold ourselves
accountable which Jonathan will talk a
little bit about in a in a minute um and
then of course
um as as the wheel says like or
indicates we have all of these different
programs that rely on Medicaid funding
so we have our Med our division of
Medicaid services but we're just not in
a vacuum at the department or in the
state we're constantly interacting with
Chris's teams and Trisha's teams um we
have Jonathan as a Med medical oversight
that works really closely with division
Youth and Family Services on what those
children's needs are so we're not a
siloed Division and we're really hand
inand with all of the different
divisions at the department
understanding what those programmatic
needs are where the Medicaid funding is
I think um what will be really
interesting and what you'll be wanting
to understand next week with Henry is
really how does that Federal match work
what does that mean what part is the is
the state paying versus what the federal
um government is paying for our Medicaid
Program here in New Hampshire and how
that may change depending on different
programs and what that match looks like
um I'm going to stop there I'm going to
ask Jonathan if you have anything sure
I'd like to mention accountability I
mean so of The 100 84,000 individuals
that are covered for with Medicaid in
New Hampshire uh it's actually a small
population in Medicaid terms compared to
most States even of states that are
comparable of size to New Hampshire
that's because New Hampshire is a
healthy State you know in the rankings
we are among the healthiest states in
the country but that's not true among
our Medicaid population and so we we
want to make improvements and continue
New Hampshire being the healthiest state
in the country we really have to be
accountable to you and to taxpayers with
good stewardship of those funds and so
that's why you'll hear from director
Meredith tus director Henry Litman in
subsequent uh talks about
accountability how we do that through
contracts and and other mechanisms so
there's a real connection between our
Medical Services Unit and Medicaid with
driving the accountability in those
contracts for the good stewardship of
those funds don't want to get into the
weeds we will in the future but the
example is that with the MCO contract we
want to make sure that we are uh
reducing cost and using those funds
efficiently and one mechanism that we do
that is to have a coordinated system for
those individuals that are covered
through Medicaid we collect over
300 uh U metrics from the mcos on how
the population is doing from claims data
to actual quality data uh for the how
healthy people
are um we one Central One Central metric
example is the percentage of patients
that have a primary care doctor who see
that primary care doctor and have a
health physical checkup with their
primary care doctor that's an example of
a metric that we H use very heavily in
our
contracts as far as uh assessing
liquidated damages to to mcos if the
patients do not have that or rewarding
them through mechanisms such as
performance-based Auto assignment
assigning more patients to an MCO who's
doing a better job of connecting
patients to a primary care doctor the
idea here is we're reducing costs by
having a coordinated system Primary Care
is far cheaper than an individual being
hospitalized or having a a necessary
emergency room visit so that's just a
diving into a little bit of a way that
we want to be accountable and be very
mindful that these are taxpayer funds
they're not
ours thank you Jonathan and just to
highlight the number of individuals on
Medicaid in the state of New Hampshire J
about
185 um 185,000 just just to put that in
perspective of almost 990,000 of those
are children too so it's important to
know that we're really ensuring that our
future our children are getting the best
health that they can possibly get to
ensure that their livelihood and and
self-sufficiency when they're older is
there so I think that's really
critical we can stop there we have a
really detailed presentation I'm
prepared for next Monday on Medicaid 101
the difference of Medicaid and medic
Medicare and all of the different as I
said funding component components types
of populations covered eligibility
process um funing mechanisms um and such
so if there's any um additional
questions that you would like us to
address next Monday we're happy to
include that in our presentation I know
representative Edwards has has worked
with Henry a bit to to provide an
outline of what you may expect so we're
happy to to add to that as well um or if
there are any other questions for any of
us um any um I'm I I think you're
meaning to open that up to everyone
who's spoken so far yeah uh are there
any questions from the committee uh
representative
Daniels and and just a reminder of how
we we do uh business I I put it in an
email one once I turn the microphone
over to one of uh the committee members
uh you're you're free to engage in um a
natural conversation with the people at
the desk you don't need to keep coming
back to me to ask for followup and as
long as we re maintain
a common track uh that that's that's
great I think that's a preferable way of
going so it's a little different than
other committees but go ahead
representative Daniels thank you Mr
chairman uh I actually have a number of
questions some of them are probably
short others may be a little longer uh
regarding the Staffing we we were given
a number uh does that include full-time
parttime okay I'm sorry because I can
see the logistics here right now uh
we're going to maybe start having uh
members of the audience come up there's
a bank of microphones along the seats if
you get asked to come up just grab one
of these side seats and stay there until
we're
done right we we we do want to do that
but if there's an answer an
acknowledgement let's do that too okay
uh so yeah I'd be interested in the
breakdown uh whether that 3200
uh employees uh include full-time
part-time Andor Contracting and what
what the numbers
are um Mr White I have a qu question for
him uh in the example he gave on Tanner
he said we had to spend 34 million in
order to get 38 million but then he
mentioned something for a about a
penalty and I'm wondering if we're if we
are penalized for not spending according
to Federal expectations
I can
answer
okay ex the Chris Sello associate
commissioner right now we are not in a
penalty phase with tanif but I can have
Nathan better explain it because it
starts a spiral and it's really hard to
get out of that spiral once you go down
in that but Nathan can be prepared to
talk about that and the slide that
you're asking about positions those are
only full-time authorized reflected on
that sheet if you would like something
in addition we can ask Nathan to pull
that okay thank you and and the uh to
just follow up on that the uh fulltime
does that include any positions that may
be vacant right now yes okay thank you
um I think I'll I'll wait till Thursday
because I've heard heard a lot about uh
performance measurements and one of my
questions was how how you are measuring
for
Success um
in uh in one of the earlier slides the
the commissioner mentioned a culture of
belonging and I wonder if somebody could
elaborate a little bit more what what a
means uh see Dave said he will address
that tomorrow tomorrow okay okay thank
you um on the slide that talked about
the uh Youth and older adults what is
the age range for youth and for older
adults that depends on the program but
some of our programs go for youth is 0
to 18 some go up into the 20s depending
on their particular needs Chris you
could probably have same for um aging
and adult Services some start at 18 some
start at 60 so I will map that out for
you on Thursday okay I appreciate that
um there was a mention about uh a PCP
visit uh to to kind of
keep a benchmark going uh with medic
Medicare recipients uh they have an
annual Wellness visit which as I
understand really doesn't do much except
Mark something down on paper there's not
too much physical examination or
anything like that so I curious as to
how that fits into the program I can
answer that question now so Medicaid
does not have a Medicare Wellness visit
so what we're really looking at is most
for the 90,000 children uh we since the
pandemic it's incredibly important for
them to have in-person Wellness visits
because that's where they get things
like lead screening it has to be done in
person so they have a depending on the
age primarily has a different types of
services that are recommended uh for
that type of visit but it's not like the
Medicare Wellness that don't even
doesn't even require a physical exam
these require a provider doctor other
providers you know physically examining
the patient and Performing services like
screening for elevated lead levels good
to know thank you and then my last one
has to do with uh long-term care in the
in kind of the coordination between
programs um about five years ago I
assisted my dad going through to to get
on
Medicade and we had a we get into a
situation where the facility would not
accept him until until uh we get the
okay from the Department that he was
accepted for Medicaid but medic he would
they would not accept him for Medicaid
until the facility said that they would
take him so it wasn't until we got
involved in a three-way call and the
department says well we also have
Senator Daniels on the line and suddenly
all the doors opened and everything was
okay and came together quickly and I'm
wondering you know does that kind of
situation still exist and if so how do
we get past it um I will address that on
Thursday as well um when we talk about
and some of the work in our system of
care for healthy aging actually um
altered How We Do eligibility to help
get the access at the right time but
I'll talk a little bit about the
coordination of our financial unit and
our medical eligibility unit and how
we're working together okay thank you
very much thank you Mr chairman uh are
there any other questions from the Comm
committee I I I have a couple but go
ahead I just want to make sure I heard
that correctly did I hear correctly that
Medicaid does not cover adult wellness
and annual adult
Wellness Medicare Medicare has a very
specific Medicare Wellness visit that is
different than a preventive Health visit
that would be in Medicaid the Medicare
there's two types there's a welcome to
Medicare visit and then there's the
Medicare annual visit so that's strictly
Medicare and the that type of visit that
representative Daniels talks spoke about
uh is very limited in scope for visits
that happen in Medicaid it is a fullon
physical exam in addressing the
different Health needs of that
individual person whether it's a child
or adult thanks for the clarification
and and of course you want to brag about
how in the dental program the adult
dental program we included a preventive
uh
component
absolutely um so the Medicaid population
um I'd like to know more about the kids
part of this uh later this week um we
990,000 approximately of about 185,000
I'll call that half um are kids I can't
imagine that the kids are contributing
half of the cost though I got to imagine
that the the adult side is relatively
more expensive on a per capita basis but
maybe you could share the those details
with me later we'll we'll take that down
representative Edwards and uh bring that
back to you in the next talk but I can
tell you though that um many of the
individuals that are children that
Medicaid covers have very complex
medical needs some are very high cost
and require specialized services in
other states children's hospitals in
other states and those bills can run up
in the millions or tens of Millions for
a child very quickly uh in some very
rare situations but uh so I we do need
to get the exact numbers for you as far
as the break thank you so much um and
then the other part of it is
um I I think it was mention that New
Hampshire has a higher percentage or a
very high percentage of children in the
program relative to other states I I I
think that's probably due to um the
eligibility guidelines that adults are
at about 180
185% of poverty level but we allow
children up to in the 300s or something
a much higher percentage of poverty
could you could you when you come back
just make sure uh we understand what
that eligibility uh cut off is and and
um and if there's any history around
when it got extended or contracted u in
the last 10 years or something that
would be nice context absolutely we
we're prepared to talk about the F
federal poverty limit with that is for
adults which I think is around 138% and
and then the children are much higher as
you as you mentioned but we'll bring
back those exact breakdowns and the
history of it and then if you could also
thank you could if you could also
contextualize that against the other
states I mean that's not the only bench
mark but it would be just nice to know
where where we
rank so sure um are there uh
representative Stringham yeah I just I
have a few questions in writing who
should I give them to so you can
integrate them in or um anybody or yes
okay that's all we don't have to I don't
now I'm I'm not seeing any other
questions so I I have one for U our new
clerk are you comfortable you have
everything to to to put the minutes
together for this meeting is there
anything uh that you need restated or
anyone reintroduced or anything for to
complete the
chairman I I didn't catch all the names
of the uh
presenters uh but I think I can take
those off the order
chart um if if one of you could stick
around and help us with names that would
be great sure thank thank you I think
most of all El on outstanding thank you
so much a clerk job is a very difficult
job I appreciate it I'm easing into it
yeah yeah all right um and then so I'll
ask the department last call any last
call committee last call Mr Ripple we I
never want to finish without your last
word are we okay all right uh so with
that um I'll adjourn uh this division
you
e